so I have another showing tomorrow about
a quick lunch and I can pick up
something on the way over
tomorrow I'm very busy you don't care
mine's always somewhere else
invite you Arthur my article yeah it's a
fantastic article
you made it jump know she doesn't read
my work but you think it's right that
your wife does all the heavy lifting so
you can pretend to be an intellectual
here we are Billy gasps I love that like
it's my paradise why can't you just be
because I'm too busy for absolutely
something
I detected a small bass how risky the
surgery
it's a highly invasive procedure you
believe in God the scientist that has
more on our creation than we are his if
God is not waiting for you on the other
side please
our anger and the pretending and
fighting it off but on home it is during
my darkest times but I love that once
our closest I don't want to die Arthur
and some cold empty rooms surrounded by
people are only there because it's their
job to be
FinCEN up what this is here how's that
moment yeah life-changing moment
go back there whatever you
pass me a Polish
tariffs are anything on earth
working for Howard Hughes no harm having
high hopes family and what church to go
to frame First Methodist in Fresno I
forgive you she's kidding
we're back